New Hampshire's Attorney General is
investigating three Ivy League
professors for alleged sexual misconduct
Dartmouth College said they are all
tenured members of its faculty todd
Heatherton William Kelly and Paul Whalen
teach in the school's department of
psychological and brain sciences Jericka
Duncan is on the school's campus and
Hanover with what we know about the
investigation
Jericka good morning good morning this
Ivy League college is in a remote part
of New England far away from the glitz
and glamour of Hollywood but these
accusations of sexual impropriety
against three prominent professors could
show the ever widening scope of the
Harvey Weinstein effect one of the
accused professors spoke to us through
his lawyers in a statement taht
Heatherton denied violating any college
policies including those against sexual
misconduct and harassment he has engaged
in no sexual relations with any student
this statement said graduate student
Carly bow back were you surprised when
you first heard the news absolutely I
think as a campus Dartmouth is known for
being very focused on gender equality so
to have something like this happen
strikes me as unusual and surprising
last week the school revealed it was
investigating Heatherton and two other
professors William Kelly co-director of
the Dartmouth brain imaging Center and
Paul Whalen who has his own lab and gave
a TEDx talk on campus you have forces
that you can't control conspiring
sometimes to set you off and intrude on
your day so you don't get your work done
the investigation is one of the latest
in a series involving prominent men
accused of inappropriate behavior since
allegations of rape and harassment led
to the firing of producer Harvey
Weinstein who is now under investigation
by the Beverly Hills Police Department
the exact nature of the allegations
against the professors is unclear but
five state and local law enforcement
agencies are conducting the criminal
investigation New Hampshire Attorney
General Gordon J McDonald said at this
time we have no basis to conclude that
there is a threat to the general public
Zachary Bilchik is in his first year at
Dartmouth it's concerning definitely for
like my friends
everyone I know especially my female
friends Dartmouth placed the professor's
on paid leave and restricted their
access to the campus in a message to
students and staff Tuesday Philip Hanlon
the college's president said sexual
misconduct and harassment are
unacceptable and have no place at
Dartmouth
Heather turns lawyers said he went on a
long plant sabbatical before learning
about Dartmouth investigation the other
two professors we did not hear back from
then when we asked for a comment and a
spokesperson here at the college says
they plan to cooperate fully with law
enforcement Gail all right Thank You
jurika